recently we took a look at some of the
key transformations in anime but
transformations are only a small part of
the broader topic that we're going over
today for this top 10 list we're taking
a look at power-up moments power-ups are
a key part of showing an anime and can
be made memorable so in this edition of
the top 10 list we're going over some of
the most impactful power-up scenes in
select anime without further ado let's
begin
we'll kick start this list with our ever
popular dragon slayer natsu for natsu
his key power-up came in the battle
against jalal in the tower of heaven ark
backed in the corner in a touch and go
battle that could swing either way nazi
resorts are doing one of the things he
does best eating now we all know that
dragon slayers can eat certain elements
in order to recover their strength but
what happens if a fire dragon slayer
consumes a material of pure energy much
more than the fire that he typically
eats a theory on dragon force that's
what the shadow of a dragon manifests
behind natsu and his face transforms
into one with this new power-up natsu
unleashes a flurry of attacks on jalal
to firmly take control of the fight
overall this is a pivotal moment for
fairy tales main protagonists and it
sets the expectations going forward
[Music]
our star's demon form takes the number
eight spot on the list we knew it would
only be a matter of time but astor
finally achieved one wicked demon
transformation in his battle against
ladros an evenly matched fight
apparently comes to an end as ladros
barrages arster with blasts the former's
seeming victory against his foe gets
thrown out the window though the moment
arso emerges with a black mass around
his arm it creates a horn and a wing
completing his demon transformation
despite landross's attempts at gaining
the momentum astor simply powers through
his blasts it was over the moment aster
entered this new form really regardless
this new form represents a new and
important step forward in the
development of asta's powers
[Music]
[Music]
overpowered villains require extreme
measures and bleach is eisen is by all
means a good example of an overpowered
villain for ichigo kurosaki the extreme
measure came in the form of the final
gitsuga tensho and the attacks it grants
to substitute shinigami mugetsu in many
ways mugetsu's a momentous power-up in
bleach ichigo's been a shinigami for as
long as we can remember and when i first
saw it it took a while to sink in that
in one attack he'd stake everything and
sacrifice it all no longer would he be
able to fight go to seoul society or
even be able to see ghosts it's truly an
all-or-nothing attack that seeks to end
eisen before the latter can continue
evolving past ichigo's power level
[Music]
rounding out the bottom half of the list
is none other than gold experience
requiem can we really talk about jojo
power levels without going over gold
experience requiem giorno's requiem stan
spawned a lot of discussions and jokes
due to how ridiculously overpowered it
is can anyone be gold experience requiem
is a common thread topic who can blame
the people though how could you top the
ability to revert the state of things
and i don't mean puny healing i really
mean something more closely described as
reverting actions and willpower to the
state of zero it also came out in an
important part of the golden wind anime
who among those who watch gold and wind
can forget how this stand absolutely
demolished diavolo who got stuck in a
death loop gold experience requiem is
one broken power-up that raised the bar
for jojo's already wacky power level
scale
mud
[Music]
starting the upper half of our list is
aaron's coordinate power well this is a
game changer who knew that these
man-eating monsters that humanity feared
for so long could be controlled to see
more comrades die is one thing but to
see one killed in the exact way that
your mother was should be more than
traumatizing it finally was for eren as
he comes face to face with the smiling
titan encouraged by mikasa's words aaron
yells in rage and faces the titan head
on letting loose a punch he activates
something that would soon be revealed as
the coordinate ability with this power
he unwittingly activates a command that
sends all titans within the vicinity
into a furious charge seeing eren
unleash the coordinate ability for the
first time opens up questions and
mysteries
luffy's conqueror's haki is fourth on
our list it's fitting that for a series
full of battles and creative powers one
of the most impactful power-ups is an
ability that doesn't involve direct
fighting yeah i'm talking about
conquerors haki an ability that allows
the user to overwhelm others using
willpower the user the one who possesses
the power of a king will render those
with weak wills unconscious during the
marine foot arc whitebeard finds himself
unavailable to intervene on aces
execution it's here that luffy unleashes
the ability once more causing the
executioners to faint the pirates
reaction to the revelation that is
actually the conqueror's haki is just
priceless who knew that luffy would be
in possession of such an amazing ability
[Music]
[Music]
bad things happen so what do you do when
the world and fate turn against you turn
it into a broken power of course just
like obito did witnessing the death of
rin's a turning point in obito's life it
takes certain strength to stay up when
you see the girl you love die at the
hands of a friend instead kakashi and
abito respectively awakened to the power
of the mangakyo sharingan unlike
traditional mangekyo users obito doesn't
seem bothered by none of those bleeding
eye effects it also gives him a nifty
power in the form of his teleportation
ability kamui kamui has become obito's
favorite ability since then being the
signature and most important part of his
arsenal as toby after all who can say no
to intangibility and the ability to
traverse dimensions i guess that just
shows how impactful abitos mangekyo is
who knows what could have happened had
his mango not awakened surely the
history of the ninja world would have
been a lot different
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
at number two we have gohan going super
saiyan 2. a lot of 90s kids would have
surely remembered this transformation
gohan entering super saiyan 2 during the
cell arc was in my experience one of the
most memorable power-ups back in the day
this happens after cell crushes android
16's head ending his short life touched
by the android's final words and enraged
with his death gohan's rage reaches its
limit and transforms him into a new
level thanks to this moment it's no
longer about goku or vegeta for the kids
then in one transformation gohan becomes
the coolest character for many of us
after all the teasing the show had about
this form seeing gohan entering it and
dominating the sales juniors was a
breathtaking experience this leads to an
exciting and hyped showdown between
gohan and cell himself
[Music]
the moment deserving of the top spot on
our list of impactful power-ups is one
that transcends the medium yep not only
was tanjiro and nizuko's power up
against rui a key moment in the show
it's probably the one that allowed demon
slayer to transcend anime into pop
culture much like attack on titan did
half a decade ago the fight against rue
is nothing too special on the surface of
it protagonists fight villains they
start losing a timely flashback
revitalizes their resolve and they get a
power-up to finish with a win but a
fight more than a sequence of events
especially in a medium-like anime
besides the noteworthy animation the
soundtrack and voice acting was on point
it all leads to this power-up moment
leaving goosebumps all over those who
watch this show if demon slayer wasn't
already on the map this power-up moment
sure put it there with its engaging
story and visuals demon slayer deserves
it it's a work of art
[Music]
and that does it for today take note
that this ranking is purely based on my
opinion so i'd really love to hear your
take on these rankings i'm sure that you
have other power-ups in mind so why
don't you drop some scenes that you